Alright guys, so in this video, we are going to learn about autoblocks now
I'm pretty sure that you guys have heard a lot about autoblocks and
If you've been watching a lot of YouTubers for Xtraders
I'm pretty sure that by now you know about autoblocks, but
Just for the sake of this course, I'm gonna still teach it
All right in my own way. That's how it makes sense
So what is an autoblock?
Now if you are new you should be listening very very carefully
So when we get an impulsive move I
Will repeat when we get an impulsive move to the downside or to the upside
Price is going to leave out some imbalance or fair value gap. All right
now
above
now the first candle
Of that fair value gap that creates the
Remember we talked about three candle pattern, right? So we got one pet one candle two candle and a third candle
Okay, so as I've said before I'm going to explain to you autoblocks in my own way. All right, I
Believe it works way better
than what other people are teaching because if you I'm going to say it quickly if you have been watching a lot of
Videos they always tell you that you should always pick the very last candle of that impulsive move, but that is absolutely wrong. All right, so
First of all you want to identify imbalance. All right, so we talked about the third three candle pattern
So there's one candle. This is the second candle and this is the third candle. All right, and we got fair value gap
Around this
So this is fair value gap now the very first candle, which is this. All right, that is your autoblock
Okay, so you just mark it out and
This is from where you should be entering if you want to enter off the autoblocks. I
Sometimes I enter off the autoblock if the imbalance is too big. Okay, sometimes I just be direct the entering
from the imbalance so
This is basically autoblock guys what you want to determine first of all is a
Impulsive move it could be as you can see this is an impulsive move and by impulsive move I mean
a price action that leaves imbalance, okay, and
What we should be always keeping in mind is that we should be only?
Considering the autoblock and imbalance in the premium zone if we are looking to sell. Okay, so we are looking to sell right
So then we're gonna draw out our fib and you can see price is above the 50% level. So
Yeah, you can buy a
Sorry, you can short it right around one price, which is the imbalance or for the
optimized entry you can just
put your short position at this autoblock and
Yeah, boom that is it. So
I'm not gonna explain a complicated stuff. I'm just gonna
Teach you in the most easiest way so you can understand easily. Okay, don't overcomplicate things guys
It's just I don't know. There's so many gurus that overcomplicate autoblock so much. All right, so
keep that in mind and
Impulsive move that creates some sort of imbalance in the premium or discounted zone. All right, and then the first candle I
Don't care if it's a bearish candle or a bullish candle. I
Just want it to be the first candle of that imbalance. Okay, so remember three candle pattern one two three
The low of the first candle the high of the sec a third candle. All right, so I'm gonna explain it again
Just in case you didn't understand
So this is imbalance, but if the imbalance is too big I
enter of the
Autoblock which is this candle the beginning of that autoblock put your stopwatch right above it and
Boom. Okay. Now. This is of course hindsight. Huh, so yeah
This is a autoblock now. Let me give you an example for
For
If I can find it of course, okay, I think I do find it and I think this is in a
That I'm all right. Yeah, so we got the
Example here, but this is not the perfect example, but I'm just still gonna teach it. All right, so we see we got a pull
push up
Push down and then we got another leg up. So we are gonna go first of all draw a Fibonacci tool
So you can see this in an impulse and move that leaves the imbalance behind all right
So let me draw this out right around here. Okay, so perfect voila
Now after the impulse and move to the upside we are going to wait for the price to fall down into the discounted zone
Which is below 50% of the Fibonacci tool perfect great now
Where is the imbalance?
You
Can see that we see imbalance around this level all right, so we got imbalance
But the problem with it is that
It is above to 50 person all right
But if you look
Just below it
You can see that this is on autoblock
Okay, the first candle
That creates the imbalance okay, so
Price falls into this autoblock
But then we got
Another fair value gap around this level okay
So we should be considering this as our autoblock
And if we draw this out you can see how perfect our entry is
So you would have gone long here of course your stop laws was a bit huge
But look we are on a one minute time frame. So this is very small okay and
Boom and I'm explaining it on a one minute time frame just to show you guys that price is fractal okay
so I
Hope you understood what I talked about here. Okay, first of all we saw an imbalance around here
But the imbalance was above the 50 person area okay, but then price fell into this
discounted
Autoblock now you kind of entered here as well
Okay, as I said before I sometimes enter off the imbalances if the imbalances short
I would enter here and as you can see in this scenario
The imbalance was small so I would have entered at this level, but
If you are only entering off the autoblocks
then you want to see you want to mark out the
The autoblock in the discounted zone, so this was the first if you did enter here
Congrats, okay
But as you can see the imbalance was about 50% this this could have been a risky trade okay
But then this autoblock was way below the 50% level
Way to discount it. Okay, so this is like the perfect place for you to buy and
Price falls into this level. Of course you're gonna enter a little above your actual entry to
deal with the spreads of your broker and
As you can see price went all the way up
very very simple guys, okay
Not complicated at all
Let me see if I can give you another example and then I'm gonna end the video so
Now of course this is hindsight guys and yeah, you know and
Okay, so let me see
Okay, so
We got the
market structure break now I consider wicks sometimes as
A break as well because you know, it's just showing a shine a sign of strength the price
Can go up all right, so I consider it as a market structure break as well and
Now you're gonna see that we got this autoblock right around here
Now of course
I'm just telling you guys if you're just entering
Only because of the autoblocks you're gonna lose a lot because yeah, of course my job is to teach you autoblocks
But I don't don't usually recommend using autoblocks like this, but for the sake of this video
I'm just gonna teach you anyways, okay, so as you can see price broke through this level, so
We're gonna first of all draw our Fibonacci to
right wait for the price to fall down into the premium or sorry discounted zone price comes down to the discounted zone and
We got this imbalance here. So now I would personally directly enter off this imbalance
Which is around here so you can see we have gotten this move right up right up there
but then as you can see we got this autoblock all right and
and
Price fell into it probably stopped you out of course it did because in my opinion if you're using autoblocks like that
You're always gonna lose. I'm pretty sure that you have watched a lot of SMC videos
Or you bought someone else's course and they taught you that you should be buying a daughter block putting your stop
Let's write below it a bit eventually it gets topped out a lot in my strategy videos
I'm gonna clear everything to you. So don't worry about it, but I'm pretty sure you should be
clear about autoblocks
This was a long video and unnecessarily long video, but I did hope I do hope that you got some information out of it
So don't just rely on autoblocks guys. I mean yeah, they are helpful
But in a different way and I'm gonna teach you that different way. So see you guys in the next video